TRYING TO STOP
>> A HISTORY OF GOING FROM THE
>> CARL HAGELIN HAS IT, CENTER
FOR OUT STACK UP0.
MINNESOTA IS JUST WIN.
>> PLAYING ACROSS OFF.
RIGHT IN THE HEAT
GOAL.
>> S.
I THINK IF HE HAS HIS OWN STICK,
HE DOESN'T HAVE
MAY BE SITTING A LITIT ZUCCAREL.
THEN HE COULD NOT QUITE
HARTMAN. CREDIT.
>> DEFENDED BY MATT DUMBA.
ACROSS THE ICE. SWAMPED
AND MINNESOTA WILL BE
SHORTHANDED.
AND THEN BATTLING AND WE HAVE
HOCKEY HE HAS SEAN, YOU LOOK ATD
IT'S ALMOST SURE AND
HE WAS BLOCKED AS WELL.
BACK TO THE NET AND HE KNOCKS IS
THEY FINALLY MANAGED TO TIE IT
UP SO THAT'S PRETTY ABOUT IT.
A COUPLE OF THE 2-1.
>> HAVING TO MAKE A DIVING SAVE.
REMAINING OVER THE MINNESOTA EN.
>> ONE OF THE GREAT SHOOTOUT
SPECIAIA HE TRIES TO HAVE A
CHANGE>> THIS MAN ATTACKS WITH .
IN KEVIN FIALA THE FEEL OF THE
STICK.
ALL YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS GETS.
AND